rusia confirmó su ataque en chapín según
el ministerio de defensa un misil
iskander mató a militares ucranianos que
estaban listos para viajar al actual
epicentro de la guerra de sueños un poco
más de 200 reservistas de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas murieron junto a 10
piezas de equipo de combate que se
dirigían a la zona de combate activo en
bombas fueron destruidas por el impacto
directo de muy 100 / militar en la
estación de tren de chaplin en la región
de tipo petrovski chapín se ubica 145
kilómetros de doni ask misiles rusos
alcanzaron una estación de tren causando
la muerte de civiles según las
autoridades ucranianas incluyendo
menores de edad 10 y moscú tienen dos
versiones distintas de lo ocurrido en la
localidad
nuestro
rumbo de las operaciones de búsqueda y
rescate en la estación del tren
continuará definitivamente haremos si
los ocupantes paguen por todo lo que han
hecho sin ninguna duda expulsaremos a
los invasores de nuestra tierra ningún
rastro de este mal quedará en nuestra
ucrania libres avancemos hacia la
victoria habrá victoria
de remo de un querido timoshenko alto
funcionario de la oficina presidencial
ucraniana afirmó en su cuenta de
telegram que el bombardeo ruso afectó
principalmente a zonas residenciales
como esta no estábamos en la casa pero
se escucharon disparos estallidos y
luego un vecino llamó y dijo que hubo
una explosión cerca de la casa la casa
quedó destruida así que esta es la
situación
los ataques rusos continúan en la región
de dnipropetrovsk donde un puesto de
mando y tres aviones de la fuerza aérea
ucraniana quedaron destruidos según
rusia
el ataque en chapín se produjo el mismo
día de la independencia de ucrania y
cuando se cumplieron seis meses desde el
inicio de la ofensiva